this is a rich [ __ ] he's a Chinese
rapper by way of Indonesia and he's very
popular on the Internet this is Joe G
he's a Japanese Australian singer and
he's also very popular on the Internet
Plus Joji invented the Harlem shake meme
let me say that again this guy Joe G in
the blood bathtub invented the Harlem
shake mean but we'll come back to that
so rich and Joe G are both signed da da
rising an entertainment company hoping
to build a lasting global brand that
will outlive singular moments of
virality
they primarily create content combining
Asian culture and HIPPA a formula that
apparently pleases the internet gods
greatly they've only been around for 18
months but they're already putting up
major label numbers I think that we have
an unprecedented collective of talent a
group of like predominantly Asian
artists you know really like making
waves globally which from an independent
point of view as well
eighty-eights founder Sean Miyashiro cut
his teeth watching advices electronic
music channel thought but quickly
Sean became interested in life beyond
dance music I knew that after launching
a whole content platform that I have
kind of the ability and they know how to
do it again but like for what was the
question so Sean moved to the Bronx to
start over and figure it out he couldn't
afford an office space so he worked out
of his car at the top of a grimy parking
garage everything kind of started here
if you look around this is my
environment this is my this is my
serenity we're really really ABA rising
was built here built on the grounds of
LA Fitness residents in a parking garage
I was living in the Bronx I'm just like
damn where the hell did I go so I just
come up here and I'd like you know I
just kind of figured things out every
single day being like okay what the hell
is this thing
coming here was kind of like my own kind
of private office basically like to be
honest I would even go to the bathroom
here I would like to take pisses here
you know anyway Mike it was you know
it's just too far to go back down there
when I need Wi-Fi I'd spend a good part
of the day at Dunkin Donuts hi how are
you can I get a chicken snack wrap
before 88 rising officially launched
Shawn caught a surprise break in the
form of a Twitter friendship with a
funny 16 year old kid from Indonesia
named Brian who taught himself English
by watching it Rubik's Cube tutorial
videos on YouTube seriously that's true
I thought his Twitter was genius from
the future just crazy and like just the
[ __ ] that he was saying like the memes
he was making
but I didn't know that he rapped or
anything like that I really didn't and
he came up with that stick like two
weeks later 12:00 in the morning pop
she's been living there baby girl that's
dick which Brian's first ever attempt at
making a rap song and it immediately
went viral everything was great about it
but there's one thing that I notice as a
song was hard as hell just like
everything about it man just like was
medicine bro soon after the video
dropped Brian signed with 88 rising I'll
FaceTime with bridge sorry for calling
you rich - got my phone rich he gets me
I mean Brian he gets like super pissed
off that he's saved in my phone is rich
shake his idea - my night might not a
human - you was good bro hey so Brian
could definitely rap but some viewers
understandably took offense at a Chinese
kid satirizing rap cliches in calling
himself rich shigga but if a group of
well-known rappers saw the video and
genuinely liked it that could at least
help validate Brian as a legit hip-hop
artist plus it could be really funny it
was just kind of an idea that kind of I
just had on the spot everything that
rappers say is better and funnier and
smarting or whatever you know there's
more entertaining we just edit it as
tight as possible put it up and it
really works no joke crying a Reebok
pepper
this is the hardest [ __ ] of all time he
said we come for sugar like me I was but
it's just late and I think people would
take it as people take it as a joke at
first but it's like if he ran with that
and kept doing more videos like this the
reaction video also went viral and even
led to a remix of that stick
featuring wu-tang this Ghostface I'll
get on that track and yeah
the remix went viral too Brian has since
acknowledged the misstep in his name who
claims he may change it but for the time
being he's still rich chigga to his fans
an ever-growing global audience
hungry for more releases from emerging
talent around the world I didn't know
that it was gonna gonna be this
impactful and this importance of people
and I'm I'm very thankful and blessed
that it has and every day now that you
know wake up it's it's like you know
it's just like a new mission every day a
major part of that mission involves Joji
remember the bloody bath guy he's a
former YouTube personality in the middle
of a career transition the sound of this
this song will he is it's like a trap
song that you can like slow dance to
awkward prom [ __ ] here I mean
I used to do crazy episodic internet
videos it was going well and one day it
was me it was me and a few friends just
in a room we were we were casually
chilling and then someone plays the song
and it is brand new at the time I happen
to have a lot of costumes laying around
so I told the other guys I get in these
costumes and let's just dance to it like
who cares we were like okay let's let's
just go crazy at the drop so that video
goes up I go to sleep in the next
morning everyone were like next morning
that taught me a lot about the internet
how people want to just be a part of
something and from that point on
something changed and I was a little
better at understanding demographics and
people and you know what they want to
see and what they want to hear I was
friends with a couple other artists who
were affiliated with 88 and then I also
started to realize that 88 is is the
bridge between Western and and and Asian
entertainment and I really wanted to be
part of that Jody just released the in
tongues EP his first project as a
serious artist Jody's in tongues record
came out a couple weeks ago um it's
number two on billboard on the R&B
charts which is crazy for you know
independent release and he's like a
brand-new artist and the success is even
more impressive knowing he went from
creating something like this to creating
something like this the newest music
video for his song demons
[Music]
tonight rich chigga has a show in New
York City tickets sold out in an hour
oh gee you guys top the new EP and I
just thought I made me cry this is
actually kind of exciting
every time this never gets old like you
live online in social media but like
there's nothing like just being with the
people
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
more often than not viral success
happens by accident and then after an
appearance on Eleanor Jimmy Kimmel
the creator star power fizzles out but
idiot rising has figured out how to turn
potential gimmicks into brands with an
actual fall that keeps coming back for
the next thing oh so keep an eye out for
ad eights next move the more than likely
it won't be covered on that work
television or terrestrial radio although
as they've already proven now it is that
really doesn't matter
you